bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous quel regard est ce que vous portez
sur la couverture médiatique de cette
manifestation hier
ah ben c'est assez étrange de voir comme
elle a été effacée des jt c'était
vraiment une couverture très pudique et
de la part des médias français je pense
parce que déjà cette manifestation
montre l'échec de la politique
sécuritaire du gouvernement les
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
en a des milliers de personnes dans la
rue sans gestes barrières bien entendu
donc c'était compliqué à expliquer
pourquoi on verbalise est des gens sur
les plages et puis pourquoi la
finalement on a lancé les lacrymo à la
fin comme d'habitude mais que la
manifestation a eu lieu
donc je pense qu'il ya là la
responsabilité du préfet l'allemand
engagé et puis il ya un vrai sujet sur
ces sans papiers c'est pas la peine de
dire j'ai entendu c'est là que ce
rassemblement à les propager le virus au
sein de la communauté des sans papiers
s'est fait depuis longtemps dans les
centres de rétention administrative dans
les lieux clos et foyer où ils peuvent
être le virus n'a pas attendu les
manifestations pour se répandre
donc c'est normal qu'ils puissent
demander de ça puis un problème plus
vaste derrière comme ça a été entendue
dans le sujet c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas de papiers mais qui travaille donc
sur dans un vide juridique dont qui
demandent des papiers pour travailler
beaucoup sont là et travail et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
notamment dans le secteur agricole des
récoltes qui ne sont pas récoltées par
manque de bras or vous avez ici des gens
qui sont sur le territoire national
certains sont portés volontaires
d'ailleurs pendant la crise du provident
et le confinement pour aller récolter
avait des papiers ils étaient réguliers
de réguler réguliers et je pense que la
france a été un des rares pays européens
à ne pas régulariser massivement pour
éviter ce problème l'ajustement donc une
erreur de plus qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on va devoir de toute façon faire face à
ce problème là parce que ce sont des
travailleurs parce qu'on a besoin de
bras aussi dans le secteur agricole ou
ailleurs et qu'il va falloir un moment
faire le choix de régulariser pour
éviter ces idioties administratives
telles que nous vivons la manifestation
était annoncé a depuis plusieurs jours
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
retrouvées hier on a quand même du mal à
comprendre
raisons pour lesquelles si peu de
télévision notamment ont couvert
l'événement est ce que selon vous la
pandémie à déplacer l'attention des
médias vers la santé publique au
détriment d'autres sujets non puisque là
vous avez un sujet de santé publique
extraordinaire si vous avez des millions
de gens qui est sans lest barrière se
réunissent et brisbart règle des dix
personnes dont je pense que c'est
vraiment sûr il faut voir que depuis le
début de cette crise beaucoup de médias
se sont mis en mode propagande pour
revendre leur fait les mesures du
gouvernement faire de l'esprit cathy
faire beaucoup de pédagogie comme on
appelle ça aujourd'hui de manière
ludique expliquer ce qui se passe et là
patatras sa déconfite d'un côté les
parcs
donc je pense qu'on a beaucoup parlé on
s'est retrouvés parquet puis c'est le
retour des manifestations c'est le
retour des revendications et ça va me
faire qu'empirer jusqu'à jusqu'en
septembre où en plus on risque d'avoir
un mois de septembre socialement très
difficile avec de nombreux nouveaux
chômeurs qui vont venir s'inscrire en
catégorie à donc je crois que c'est
volontaire de ne pas avoir couvert cet
événement certains l'ont fait comme vous
et d'autres médias heureusement mais
sinon là on ne peut plus aider le
gouvernement dans son art attifé est en
fait il ya aussi cette maîtrise du temps
c'est à dire que si on faisait de ce
sujet le sujet le plus important et
c'était un sujet très important ça veut
dire qu'on est passé à autre chose
or l'épidémie est toujours là et puis on
voit bien que comment voulez-vous
derrière expliqué à des français avec
des papiers qu'ils ont pris des amendes
parce qu'ils étaient sur une plage à
deux personnes
ou bien parce qu'ils ont une malheur
d'être devant un tribunal et d'attendre
le verdict à plus de 10 personnes
et puis que vous avez une manifestation
avec des milliers de personnes à paris
mais vous aviez hier aussi je sais pas
si vous en avez parlé là la
manifestation à maubeuge contre la
fermeture de l'usiné renault donc on
voit bien que de toute façon le temps
des manifestations on reprend et peu
importe quelles sont les lois
d'exception liberticide qui seraient
encore en place
elle vole en éclats par par le réal
après deux ans il faut donc s'attendre à
une multiplication de ce type de mal
festation de rassemblement oui je pense
que c'est que le début on voit en plus
le climat aux états unis de 10 me pierre
civile de suite à la mort de georges
paul pas par les policiers je crois que
on n'a pas oublié les gilets jaunes
n'ont pas oublié non plus qu'est ce qui
se passait tous les samedis on attend de
voir quelles sont les revendications
mais le peuple français a été
extrêmement méfiant il a tout fait pour
enrayer la propagation ce virus mais à
un moment on se rend bien compte aussi
que peut-être que ces lois d'empêcher le
rassemblement
quand on va ouvrir et centres
commerciaux puis ouvrir les restaurants
puis d'ouvrir le reste ça ne tient pas
debout en fait donc le choix sera de
faire de la revendication
il ya eu d'ailleurs des intermittents du
spectacle qui se monte à 1 m chacun sur
la place du trocadéro pour pour
revendiquer mais tout ça c'est c'est de
leur tour en fait à la vie normale entre
guillemets puisqu'elle ne sera pas
normal puisqu'il va falloir reconstruire
après après les communes mais le fait
est qu il ya une envie de découvrir les
luttes sociales et qui selon vous va
descendre dans la rue les plus précaires
on imagine mais ceux qui ont aussi le
sentiment d'avoir été oubliés pendant le
confinement oui bah tous ceux qui ont
beaucoup perdu
là on parle de de gens qui n'avaient pas
de papiers donc qu'il travaillait dans
dans la clandestinité beaucoup dans la
restauration où notre secteur donc cela
vaut en décembre et puis tous ceux qui
vont perdre leur emploi tous ceux à qui
on a fait de belles promesses qu'ils ne
pourront pas arrivé je parlais de la
manifestation à maubeuge pour lutter
contre la fermeture des usines renault
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce qui
intéresse le pouvoir c'est d'éviter les
faillites d'aider les grands groupes les
pme tpe que ce soit dans le monde du
spectacle de la restauration les salles
de sport les lieux d'accueil eux sont
toujours en lutte avec les bailleurs qui
refuse de leur faire des cadeaux
enfin pas des cadeaux même pas d'être
juste responsable et de ne pas leur
demander de loyer pour ces deux mois ou
n'ont pas pu exercer d'activité je crois
que beaucoup de
d'entrepreneurs de petites entreprises
aussi vous être prêt dans colère s'il
n'y a pas de mesures fortes qui sont qui
sont faites pour eux donc turda perdu
pendant ce confinement sauf jeff bezos
ce et amazon qui a encore multiplié sa
fortune de plusieurs milliards mais mais
pour pour les petites entreprises en
france les indépendants ces gens là qui
était sans papiers de 7 à un monde
compliqué sans vraiment de réelles
politiques décidées par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
cofondateur de la revue le monde moderne